on a peur que les musulmans s'assimile à
la france et qu'il ne pense pas l'islam
c'est une différence entre vous vous
vous acceptez je pose l'islam comme à
roubaix mais d'innombrables centrales
étrangères moi je leur ai dit monsieur
moi je le redis pour être mes frères il
faut que vous acceptiez la france telle
qu'elle est nous l'avons vous avez des
frères et soeurs ap oui et vous leur
avez dit pour qu'on soit frères et
soeurs il faut vous acceptiez je sais
pas quoi alarmer mais là certes et oui
mais là monsieur mélenchon c'est des
enfants adoptés et quand il ya des
enfants adoptés comme moi je le fus
d'ailleurs mes proches donc quelques
elle trouvera comme vous vous le foot
excusez moi un nom pour messi messi boys
ou messi moi je suis français j'ai rien
demandé aussi je venais jouer les cartes
d'identité de francs mais moi la
différence avec vous ouais moi je prends
content de mes ancêtres et de nos
ancêtres ben vous des enfants
sont ils ne commence pas avec vous ça
vous ne voulez pas comprendre et oui la
france ne commence pas aujourd'hui ou
même en ce sens qu'elle a dit ça vous
mine où messi ne venez pas mais il
recommande que nous comprenons non non
c'est la ville de man 50 ans - regardez
les gens même ceux qui sont pas de mon
avis c'est pas le sujet pour moi un pour
moi c'est tous des compatriotes avons
aussi regardé nous comme on est regardé
comme on est différent
regardez comment même temps on fait
peuple ensemble voilà c'est ça qui met
en avant avec une clôture nasa à la
coupe dodge à mélangeant saviez vous qu
en pensez on fait un peuple et au fait
une nation si on a une culture commune à
partir du moment où il ya deux
civilisations qui sont sur le même
territoire on ne peut pas faire une
culte à bon eh ben non donc les
musulmans ne sont pas français pour vous
donc les musulmans français sont pas
français selon qu'ils sont musulmans
l'essai n'aurait pas du tout ah bon
c'est vous qui allez leur dire qu
on va vous voulez écrire des prières de
jeu de la bible posé une question sur
une blanche a répondu eric zemmour et
pour lui-même à ses questions donc non
non je les musulmans français de son
émission les français de confession
musulmane
sont évidemment français a su bien je
serai toujours dit sauf que j'ai aussi
non oui sauf si voilà sauf si et comme
vous vous allez changer d'avis parce que
moi je suis de la révolution ces
dernières vous imaginez que je vous dise
monsieur zemmour vous êtes français sauf
si on nous avait dit exactement ce qu'on
m'a dit qui vous a dit ça clermont
tonnerre la révolutionnaire il m'a dit
rien aux juifs en tout cas autant qu'aux
nations tout juif en tant que quand il
ya du bon dans la révolution à voyez
donc moi je dis la même chose en
mouvement je dis la même chose aux
musulmans rien aux musulmans en tant que
nation en tant qu on m'a tout aux
musulmans en tant qu'individu ah bon
alors comme dit la montagne en juillet
alors et vous dit à toutes les
communautés religieuses rien en tant que
communauté religieuse solim rien with
the nation sur la tête mais les gens qui
ont une retraite aux missionnaires mon
cher et ça devrait vous nous empêchez le
duc de clermont tonnerre qui a dit ça
pour toutes les raisons que vous savez
mais oui mais oui eh bien je dis la même
chose au musée mais la révolution comme
moi alors à billère s'ajoutent les
toutes les histoires de france me
passionne
et l'histoire de la révolution aussi
mais déjà votre place à sa place les
rois de france que vous aimez tant on
this way onze fois les juifs le grand
saint louis d'accord a inventé un signe
distinctif pour les juifs aient inventé
le percement de la langue au fer rouge
pour ce qui était des hérétiques qui l'a
imité le monde messieurs françois
feutrier l'a imité sur le monde musulman
que savait la baby rolls ginevra vous et
où ben oui mais c'est intéressant obsédé
mais oui il en ramène musulmans dans le
monde chrétien il ya des choses qui me
l'avait aussi d'être relevés qui sont
intéressants ebadi pendant des siècles
et dit qu'il rassure les musulmans qui
ont été conservés les textes de
lentilles de célébrer ses racines ses
fours historia guggenheim parce que ça a
démontré le contraire